[Applause]
how'd it feel going to the games winning
two gold medals do lighting am tell me
it was worth it if it wasn't how about
you you go to Moscow next summer I want
to know exactly what's wrong look around
you love to everybody now imaginably
bodies you all buried to get here games
Chaplin the discus and shot their
weapons don't kid yourself you're here
to kill anybody guessing your way and
all the rest is bull I could have been a
man's coat you actually think that Chuck
Noll has to worry the Franco Harris is
gonna cry because Terry Bradshaw will
talk to him Jack Lambert can't play cuz
now blood hurries things
when Swans pregnant Rocky Bleier forgot
his Tampax
[Music]
I don't know what scares you more
getting beat by Tory Skinner or beating
[Music]